I have no problem with political
polarization if it's net effect is that
of truth yeah what's virtuous about
being moderate in the face of someone's
life being turned into ruins by lies you
don't get to lie and then defame the
person fighting that lie for polarizing
America top five leftist hoaxes of 2019
so question of the day let me ask you
this genuinely how do you vet news
stories today if you read or hear
something interesting what do you do to
determine the veracity I'm really
curious let me know because it was
getting pretty difficult so very
obviously I believe that the left is
wrong and Wilson why do you see right or
left shut up
I believe it reminds me wrong everything
means wrong not dishonest right but we
have seen a new threat emerging in 2019
in the past they would usually bolster
their claims the progressive left with
was evidence that maybe we didn't think
supported we would disagree right on a
TIA that it's supported their
conclusions but now there is a movement
and when I say this I mean Hollywood
media and those in the DNC so I know
someone out there like I'm a classical
liberal I get it not talking about you
right Ruben they've pivoted to
completely false hoaxes to support the
majority certainly a plurality of their
political agenda so we're gonna look at
top 5 verifiable hoaxes perpetrated by
the left in 2019 and we're not even at
summer break yet don't keep in mind the
MTV VJs just packed up their tarp from
Cancun and we already had five to go
through show you what number five
Cavanaugh rape hoax obviously is a
pretty big analyst saying what's that
2018 know it happened this year
that's how slowly it's going by so after
the investigations they showed us that
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
didn't have any kind of a record
suddenly Democrats they trotted out
lines of women claiming that he not only
assaulted them sexually but he rang he
would run gate tape how can you make
rape gang ring sound worse I just did
and they did it right before the vote so
it's less people think I'm exaggerating
because a lot of people forget here you
go indelible
in the hippocampus is the laughter she's
a Dodge thirty
her name is Juliette Nick publicly
identified herself and alleged that
Cavanaugh and others in the early 1980s
liked the drinks of girls at high school
parties with intoxicants to make it
easier for them to be gang-raped
okay so gay rape gag rings gang rings at
very different they say five comes fast
if you do they'll make sure that never
make Supreme Court lucky for her
accusations by the way completely fell
apart before we get to the gang rape she
couldn't determine the place where the
alleged assault happened right the
people she remembered being there they
deny the event ever having taken place
yeah she couldn't remember the year it
happened and outside counsel concluded
there was no there would be no
reasonable prosecutor who'd bring
criminal charges against the judge her
story kept changing history went on by
the way her therapist the notes from her
therapist presented a completely
different account than the one that she
gave and her hearing that Julie sweat
Nick she just mentioned made the gang
recap is a gang rape accusations I
cannot say that after mulling it over
understanding potentially a threat of
surgery she walked it back a little bit
he was getting rapist what's what optics
are what optics are bad here namely that
I lied about gang rape in the world we
are lying about gang rape the third
accuser admitted by that she's never
even met Kavanagh that was one two three
after the three miseries feed the same
room with a guy one time in your life is
the highest level of hoaxes it's a
coordinated effort by Democrat activists
to push a completely false story in
order to protect a Supreme Court
nomination and of course the left they
didn't accept the results when their
hopes fell to pieces
they still smear him as a rapist and by
the way I'm not in the business of
ascribing motive or intent here but
honestly let me ask you this what is it
what does it take yeah
two out of three were verifiably
completely false they pulled it back
themselves with the only one remaining
presenting zero evidence absent the
cases where she presented verifiably
false evidence what does it take just
admit you were wrong what does it take
to just allow four innocent until proven
guilty
number four hoaxes we have to rattle
office there's so many here of course
the Russian collusion conspiracy theory
now I know this technically of course it
started years ago
go ahead in 20 M yeah Democrats refused
to accept the the results of our
democratic election of course which of
course shouldn't that should send
shivers down your spine when you talking
about democratic socialism believe in
that first part anyways the Clinton was
this result of a vast conspiracy between
Trump and record less do you think we're
making it up let's get in a DeLorean
welcome back to reliable sources every
day we're trying to keep track of the
drip drip drip of the Russia
investigations we're trying a key
election that the extent of the Russian
involvement in our presidential election
really came to light so you have seen
direct evidence of collusion I don't
want to go into specifics but I will say
that there is not circumstantial and and
is very much worthy of investigation
listen house you know I don't want to
get into specifics why is that namely I
don't have anything but I'm pretty sure
you're the devil's triangle in a rape
gate gang we conducted an investigation
cost taxpayers you and I ha ha good for
us 25 million dollars
oh wow there was no collusion there was
no obstruction yeah no criminal activity
whatsoever but we also found out that
some of the warrants for granted based
on evidence presented from sources like
the steel dossier created by fusion GPS
we've talked about that a democrat
research firm and russians so that's
kind of something that maybe we should
look into and i will say this in 2018
maybe we could have still called us a
hoax yeah or maybe would have been
unfair i guess to call it a hoax but
because we were still investigating but
but now we know was a false claim based
on false evidence yeah
proven false after two years twenty five
million dollars i mean that's his that's
his thoroughly debunked as a hoax can
get all of this Hillary Clinton she's
too clean selection Stockland as I've
been telling candidates who have come to
see me you can run the best camp
you can even become the nominee and you
can have the elections stolen from you
yes you know it's almost like she's
talking about herself this one's more
[Laughter]
calling for more investigations which is
this is what I think it's gone from hoax
to conspiracy theory and it's this curse
was almost all conspiracies it doesn't
matter how much you disprove the
conspiracy they believe it even more yes
after you provide them with research you
see with Trump in the Russians we didn't
land on the moon vaccines cause autism
or Brett Kavanaugh Iran rape gate gang
the devil triangle underground the point
is it doesn't matter if you presents at
home there's complete evidence that's
not the case or do they want you to
believe that about the Russians NASA but
I repeat myself what's happening the
earth were rotating up it you went up
friend you were in Cameroon you would
land in schenectady what I mean have you
been to Antarctica most people move to
Canada the notification bell they won't
do that because they don't believe it
exists bookmark the page because barely
notifications don't necessarily mug Club
and of course subscribe and iTunes for
some exclusive content they're hoax
number three and 2019 again this is all
the same I know people are gonna think
I'm scraping no this was really easy
yeah Jesse small at home so what did he
claim best act for people who forget the
absurdity of it and this is important to
go back I think in a look at the time
capsule kind of like when you've your 20
year high school or Union because we
need to remember what it is that
everyone believed at that moment in time
freezing Chicago night to mass Trump
supporters said this is Magga country
before they tried to strangle an import
beliefs on the attacker is the attackers
but it's also the attacks like you know
at first it was a thing of like listen
if I tell the truth
that's it cuz it's truth what the truth
it became a thing of like oh how can you
doubt that like how do you and then it
became a thing of like oh thing of like
it's not necessarily that you don't
believe that this is the truth no you
don't even want to see how many times he
said the truth no it's it's that we
don't believe it is the truth it's we
don't believe you only it is the truth
and then how can somebody like but then
you realize that's because it is the
truth how many times did you say truth
you're like give me Destiny's Child whoo
rhymed down like that was down like that
five times in case again we now know the
two Nigerian brothers worked on the show
Empire purchase the materials in the
attack we have what everybody buys those
things so this is important because the
DEA found guilty of fabricating the hook
yes
hopes hoax what is it with my ID my mom
working refuge's send some to anything
but 16 hours of community service that's
a lot and this is one of those things
this is one of the situations people
will look back in history kind of like
with OJ and I'm not saying he's like OJ
just as unlikable that guy get away with
it and that's what's so corrosive with
these hoaxes because it received
wall-to-wall coverage in the leftist
media really wanted this to be a hate
crime by Majhi at wearing racist they
really wanted that to be a case when it
fell apart they're not going to be the
ones left with eggs on their face what
they're gonna admit they're wrong where
the Kavanagh isn't a gang hoax number
two work it we're getting very near the
end of the Covington kids the hate hoax
remember the kids wearing Mogga hats
they supposedly originally in time
capsule
oh look lies they supposedly said that
they surrounded a poor Native American
Ron engine
indigenous peoples March that surrounded
this this this what's the term we use
[ __ ] risky shouting building that
wall this was the coverage Catholic High
School students seen wearing make
America great again hats appearing to
face off with Nathan Phillips a sixty
five-year-old ministries Lincoln
Memorial during an indigenous peoples
march our heard em sayings build that
wall
this is indigenous lands yeah well if he
could if the toothless meth-head claims
he heard it for me this is reliable
sources after all mr. toothless meth
head did you hear them yell out racial
epithets yes I believe that I did what
actually happened students were waiting
for their ride and they were being
harassed by black Israelites for an hour
and then they said Nathan Phillips
decided upon it turns out that he
approached the students banging his drum
in their faces here we have some video
yeah dad Wow
listen it makes more sense when yours in
that Nathan Phillips is a deranged
deranged activist who he does this all
the time after the Covington kids
controversy he tried to storm a Catholic
Church in the middle of mass begging his
driveway please take his drum and put
his head through its weight wears it
like a necklace because just cartoonish
it wouldn't hurt all just like his land
an iPhone way to live this way really
that's the updated Android seems like
just worn out that bad for you if I
don't update it they throttle my battery
[Laughter]
final one it's because five is a magic
number on YouTube so we could have done
20 there are a bunch of smaller hate
crimes hoax number one is it the whole
bunch of them because five wasn't enough
so there's like this this example was a
fake anti-semitic attack on a Jewish
restaurant in Canada this got
wall-to-wall coverage the Jewish
communities in Canada are still trying
to make sense of an alleged fake
anti-semitic attack and Winnipeg police
say the owners of a family restaurant
staged everything but the family insists
that they're telling the truth did you
fake the vandalism we didn't we didn't
because we don't talk about swastika
narwhals narwhals men during the episode
of lockup with a swastika noir wall by
the way and there were a bunch of fake
LGBT hate crimes in Portland the
reporter Andy Andy go and n go and go
and not gonna be featured on this show
anybody he researched a bunch of these
reports in supposed wave of hate crimes
you've heard about this a lot right
that's why it's important because the
narrative has been set by this wave the
surge in hate kids everywhere they found
this investigation found that they
almost all fit the pattern of being
highly publicized despite having no
evidence ultimately to know police
investigations so why are these number
one that look yeah of a bigger profile
hoax and I think of these smaller hoaxes
they actually push the narrative more
than the big ones because sewer people
know that they're hoaxes media reports
on them at one point or another and then
they turn out to be false because these
aren't as high-profile of people just
they don't hear about it they never knew
that it was a nose they all remember was
the original just like you have many
people by the way who still believe
Cavanaugh to be a rapist but not as many
because there have been enough people
like us who've been at the forefront of
that the media in Deitz the media is
very quick to and death they don't
vindicate okay by the time vindication
or truth emerges they've moved on their
super fast to indict slow to correct or
vindicate if ever yeah we're at a point
where left us they openly push hoaxes on
CNN MSNBC New York Times it's not people
at the fringe that's what's important
we have Senators Congressmen
presidential candidates pushing hoaxes
that have been conclusively disproven
okay then these people have the nerve
that's what really bothers me the nerve
to bemoan today's political polarization
as so many times and I stand by it I
have no problem with political
polarization if its net effect as that
of truth yeah what's virtuous about
being moderate in the face of someone's
life being turned into ruins by lies let
me ask you this okay let's say you're up
for a job big promotion yeah your job
okay three women come forward and accuse
you of running rape gangs which has zero
basis and truth if you don't go along
with it if you fight with every fiber of
your being are you guilty of
contributing to the office polarized
climate what if it was your kids who
were accused of a hate crime and if you
don't passionately fight back their
names their reputations ability to make
future living still be ruined for the
rest of their lives is valid obstruction
right it's obstruction it is it is the
gee willikers let's listen to both sides
milquetoast pansy more virtuous and the
person who fights back and I'm not this
is the thing I'm not gonna play this
game with less because like you see what
these hoaxes they're only going to get
worse and then when disproven they move
on you don't get to lie and then defame
the person fighting that lie for
polarizing America so this is something
I think everyone out there needs to
decide you have to take inventory of how
you've reacted to these stories okay and
ask yourself a question
what's more desirable a lie that brings
people together at the cost of
destroying everything but particularly
an innocent person or the responding
truth that sews division might be a
tough one for you for me it's pretty
easy hey there if you liked this video
subscribe or click one of these videos
playing in a box you know what hit the
notification bail because subscriptions
don't really mean anything anymore
especially if you're not 18 or older at
the very least logged in to YouTube is
18 or older because sometimes people are
25 but they don't know how to use the
YouTube system properly and then you
never just take the notification pal or
you hate yourself